what what do you know about
social about uh like russia and china
using social media as a weapon to sort
of like seed
discussions and and tear people apart
and kind of create
this descent online and so it's
interesting that you bring that up
because
uh i would say that it's not new
right that with the invention of social
media
it feels like it's new but
but foreign adversaries trying to
influence
and drive uh dissent in their against
their targets
is that's age old the brits were doing
that
against the colonialists back when we
were still you know pre-american
revolutionary war
right that's a very common influence
campaign that's what we call it in intel
terms it's a covert influence campaign
the fact that now we have tools now we
have platforms that are digital
platforms
like twitter or parlor or instagram or
facebook just because those the current
forms of mass media
doesn't change who's playing or how
they're playing or how they're playing
or what tools they're using they all you
it's all the same right
so is china and russia
messing with americans through covert
operations
to influence through social media
absolutely but so are
dozens of other countries that you're
not even considering right
the saudis are doing it the the israel
the israelis are doing it
the french are doing it the brazilians
are doing it the mexicans are doing it
just like we're doing it in
thousands of countries too you know we
do it to them of course we are because
that's that is
intel right that's how intelligence
works that's how covert influence works
you're trying to influence the outcomes
around the world
that benefit your national security
so does that mean that we're driving
dissent maybe maybe not maybe it just
means that we're trying to like
coax or encourage or lift up some
message or some candidate that we want
to see succeed in some foreign country
just like foreign countries are lifting
up candidates and messages that they
want to see succeed in our country
that is the game that is intelligence
right when when
twitter and facebook and social media
evolves
into the next great iteration of
whatever it might be whether it's
whatever vr
or augmented reality or whether we have
chips in our brains because elon musk
plugs us all in who knows
there will be something new that will
become the new platform for traditional
covert influence operations
before social media it was newspapers
and flyers and pamphlets and magazines
right before print media it was word of
mouth and stories and people traveling
and
you know drawings and pictures the
ancient courts
in egypt right the the courts of
pharaohs would play this game too where
they would try to
influence each other's courtesans and
each other's
uh heads of state so that the right
relationships or the right trade
agreements would be reached early it's
an age-old
game influence is an age-old game it's
just played with different tools
that's so crazy it's so cool i don't
understand like what would be their goal
to just
drive like outrage within the american
people like there doesn't seem like a
clear defined
path to where this goes yeah so that's
what's in this is where we start getting
into this
like the science and strategy of intel
and people don't think that way
instead you've got people who are just
kind of following the narrative of
whatever media source they listen to
whether they listen to conservative news
or liberal news and they just pair it
whatever that media source is
in covert in covert influence operations
there's
only two objectives there's either a
specific outcome that they're looking
for
or there's a chaotic outcome that
they're looking for
right that's it it's either a specific
outcome or a chaotic outcome
okay in a specific outcome it's very
very difficult to get
a specific outcome because when you're
when you're creating influence when
you're basically using
ads on twitter and facebook to reach
people
it's hard to know how those people in
mass are going to actually respond
right are they actually going to vote
for the candidate you want them to vote
for is the whole thing going to blow up
in your face somehow
are they actually going to believe the
message is out there who knows
so specific outcomes are very rare an
example of a specific outcome
is when the cia
went into iran in 1949
52 to basically unseat the to unseat the
current governor or
the leader and then put the shah in
place that was a specific
influence outcome they were trying to
shape where's the word for that
where they get people to go in there and
incite riots
uh provocateurs agent provocateurs yeah
that's that is another popular
pop culture term okay but yeah so
like that's a specific outcome those are
super hard and then it didn't work
right like the shah was there and then
the shah guy kicked out there's a whole
iranian revolution
in the history of his written itself
specific outcomes are not really the
bee's knees anymore nobody's trying to
make that happen
instead they want chaotic outcomes
chaotic outcomes are the key to all
covert influence operations
in modern day what you see russia what
you see china doing what you see north
korea doing what you see iran doing what
you see everybody doing who's messing
with our social media
all they want to do is feed the flames
that already exist feed both sides
equally
and just cause chaos because the more
chaos that ensues
the more people question the fundamental
values that make us
americans how does a democracy survive
when there's so much anger and hate how
many conspiracy theories have crept up
because people just don't have answers
to why people are doing what they're
doing
right democrats we just had a whole
corona of
coronavirus relief bill that got passed
and i have yet to hear about
it being bipartisan i have yet to hear
of a single republican congressman or
senator who participated
in voting yes right it was pushed
through
on the democratic side the same thing
happened with our health care reform
under obama pushed through
by democr by by a democrat-controlled
senate and democrat-controlled
congress when that happens
half the country gets pissed off they're
like this
isn't democracy we half of us don't want
this to happen but because a few people
hold a few seats
right now at this point in time it
happens well then what happens as soon
as the senate and the house become
republican-controlled
the exact same thing happens again but
in the opposite direction right
all of a sudden these very conservative
programs get passed and
again half the country is furious
because they're like this isn't
democracy
how does this happen that is all
our adversaries are looking for they
would rather put
money into existing messages existing
hate messages existing fear messages
existing messages about
women existing messages about minorities
existing
you know messages about immigration
about gun laws
about everything they would rather feed
that world
because it's easy for them to just cause
more chaos and let us question democracy
let us undermine ourselves from within
that's the chaotic outcome it's the it's
a much easier outcome than a specific
outcome
because the more a country like us goes
into chaos the more a country
like china or like russia in comparison
to us
looks strong right they look powerful
they gain international influence that's
the whole magic behind covert influence
that nobody seems to
understand or talk about or even want to
accept there's
no one's trying no one was trying to
make trump win
no one was trying to make biden win all
they wanted to do
was make americans hate americans and
doubt our own process
to elect the president and and i would
say
that they've been fairly successful
where does this go from here we either
grow up and we start to learn
from conversations like this we start to
recognize that we
are our own worst enemy and that
basically our enemies are just
they're just enabling us to keep like
rotting ourselves from within
so we either grow up and recognize
that's the way it works
or somehow we find a way to to
mature so that we are bigger
and better than the messages that we all
fall behind
right so it's kind of like it's like
high school i compare everything to high
school because i feel like
high school we were talking earlier
about when children develop
high school is kind of when you start
really practicing the skills
the life skills that you have right it's
when you start testing
the foundation that you've been
programmed to believe is in high school
and then everything after that is
basically just the next iteration of
high school
college is just high school without
parents right and then
your day job is just high school with
money yeah it goes on and on
um but yeah so the the my point being
that
eventually you just have to grow out of
feeling like there's bullies and feeling
like things are unfair
in order to get past high school right
you can't keep hating the
the football quarterback for getting the
you know pretty girl in the cheerleading
squad forever you have to grow past that
eventually
someday we're just going to have to grow
past the fact that politics are petty
and that we have no power the truth is
we have all the power in the world
to take petty politicians out of their
seats and put new politicians in their
place
we're just not mature enough yet to want
to admit that do we have the power to do
that though oh yeah
or do these or do the billion dollar
corporations have the power to do that
more than
more than people why do you why do we
think the billion dollar corporations
have the power
lobbyists and what do the lobbyists do
past laws that benefit their companies i
mean yes but that doesn't
that doesn't impact voters right that
impacts the companies
the voters are the ones who decide who
actually gets elected
so what actually influences the voters
media media messages right about the
candidates
right okay so your billion dollar
corporations are what
fund the campaigns that shape the
messages
that we get about about the
the candidates themselves right those
lobbyists and those billion dollar
companies
shape the the people who get elected
into an office
and then once those people are in office
it's in their best interest
to change laws to gerrymander and
whatever else right right to control
laws and make things make voting easier
make voting harder that's that's what
they do
everybody does it just like you see the
grand old party right now
trying to make it difficult to vote for
the last like
two years of the election in 2020 you
saw the democratic party trying to make
it easier to vote
right and that's just the big voting
thing back and forth who are they trying
to make it easier to vote for
people who lean democratic who are they
trying to make it
harder to vote for now people who learn
like healing democratic
everybody wants to support their own
side we do this to ourselves
because it's just another version of a
popularity contest it's it's
it's high school it's the high school
race for you know who's going to be
president
of the class right it's all high school
politics
the rest of the world doesn't need to
they don't need to to
mess that up they just need to put more
money and more
conflicting messages out there and let
us keep messing with ourselves just pour
gas on the fire and let it watch it burn
exactly that's exactly what they need to
do and in a country like ours where
everybody has rights
everybody has the right to vote
everything's transparent we have a
healthy culture that doubts the
government
most places in the world if you doubt
the government you're going to jail
you'll get you'll get disappeared off
the streets
right here we have a healthy vibrant
culture where we're allowed to
dissent if we choose so it's super easy
for the rest of the world
to mess with us you pour gasoline on
that
so